ha no honey oh my gosh tell me tell me  about this fashion honey it's Siriano  one word that's all we need  I'm so I feel like a princess at a ball  tonight and you look fabulous  Lady Gaga changed your life yes 100% she  did she talks about 99 people in  everyone believing she's my one okay I  love her so much how has being a part of  this movie and with drag queens so  present in the storyline changed your  life changed drag in general I think the  inclusion in this film and how well it's  done with Bradley just really makes  everyone feel valid it's an authentic  set of scenes and to be a part of this  and this moment it really shows a lot of  people out there you know what who you  are is worthy and you count halle-loo  and you can be anything you want look up  a Paris Texas and I'm up in here tonight  [Music]